big announcement gang the through the
roof tour is on sale right now grab the
squad and come out and see the boys
stand up comedy show you got me Kippy
de-bone Tommy C then we play little ay
with the crowd it's a good good time yes
our biggest tour to date we're super
excited we hope to see everybody again
we're going to Charlotte Nashville Tampa
Atlanta Providence New Haven Boston New
York Rochester Syracuse Albany Baltimore
Portland I ain't done yet Seattle
Vancouver New Orleans Houston Dallas Red
Bank New Jersey all tickets are
available at rug garbage.com getet on
gang we want to see you out there more
cities coming soon mhm welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody favorite
podcast this is are you garbage it's
that little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out at
the gr it to be classy yeah just a big
old piece of trash trash trash trash I'm
your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toties in the new edition she's our
clubbing oh boy yeah hitting the Rave
early in the morning shaking that tail
feather my co-host is coming at you from
across the table it's what we call
Family episode just the boys the bozos
and the homies he's a CEO of Ru garbage
he is an International businessman who
enjoys International Delights coffee
creamer give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan what up gang thanks not a sponsor
not this week yet uh thanks for tuning
in gang as always please make sure you
rate revie subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are
TR and obviously the greatest website of
all time you pull out your little
computer your phone you go over there
you download the app
www.patreon.com
slug garbage gang over 13,000 strong
the army of garbage is strong baby check
it the Freak Out gang and how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the old magic man makes
us all look good works the ones the twos
the threes and the fours crosses the
te's and he dots the eyes give it up for
T-Bone MC scruffs Toby McMullen
everybody what up boys what up T Barnes
what's up kiddo nothing I'm soaked to be
hanging with you guys fighting off the
winter Blues sure you that's a fight I'm
losing every day oh buddy the the
numbers on Call of Duty have never been
higher it's all caught up to me the dry
skin the congestion the the humidity in
the apartment everything brutal tough
out there dude it comes on quick but you
know what I do have a little bit of good
news what's that the 2024 a tour is
announced baby true the roof baby
through the roof tour baby T-Bone what's
the name of the tour true the roof oh
baby God damn we're coming this is our
biggest tour yet we're coming to a lot
of cities and this is just the first leg
I'll give you a quick rundown we got
Charlotte North Carolina Nashville
Tennessee Tampa Florida Atlanta Georgia
Providence Rhode Island New Haven
Connecticut Boston massach at The Wil
New York City New York at Town Hall that
one's already been on sale those things
are moving we got Rochester New York
Syra Syracuse New York ALB New York
Baltimore Maryland Portland Oregon
Seattle Washington Vancouver new going
to Canada New Orleans Houston Dallas and
Red Bank New Jersey get those tickets at
rug garbage.com they ain't going to be
around long scoop them up gang they're
going to go quick excited for that town
hall to Wilbur baby we're doing some
pretty big venues it's [__] awesome
shout out to the army of garbage for
making it all possible baby we love you
and we can't wait to see you out there
again I can't wait to go to New Orleans
dude get in a parade man I just end up
in one you got like theid the staff
going howy you doing I'm flashing my
heaters I'm stomping the yard we're
doing it all
Beads letting the girls out speaking of
fighting off the uh the winter Blues
yeah I have been
procrastinating uh a lot lately a lot
but I kicked it in the high gear I found
the energy cleaned out the closet oh I
did that not too long ago as well which
I have multiple generations of fat and
skinny clothes in there that I have
emotional attachments to that I just
threw it all out I kept a few things
kept a tie from my dad a leather jacket
I kept a suit that kind of fits just in
case mhm you is this the blue suit
that's the blue that thing that's got to
fit no I lost the pants the blue
checkered suit they disintegrated under
high stress that I wore in the Gilly and
ke sketch and uh the gold Brothers the
one you got for Casey and Robbie's
wedding yeah I lost them I lost them
pants okay yeah no that fits how do you
lose those crazy night that's a that's a
lot of fabric floating around
somewhere that'll Jam his sewer up
somebody sailing the high seas with that
thing okay got rid of that I just have
one um what's his name uh Mark Jacobs
Kenneth Cole Michael Kors yeah they're
all people I don't know what you want
for me I got one I got a suit there he's
in my closet the jacket fits pretty nice
we just need to get altered a little bit
but n that suit don't fit no more really
you you were pretty big when that when
you got that oh yeah big boy oh that
that doesn't fit any more to it's too
big too big so I got rid of the jacket
wow that's the first time in five years
that closed were too big for you I got I
have a bunch of them but really what it
was is that all my 5x stuff everything
has a stain on it and I'm just done with
the stain a stain multiple and I'm just
I'm done with the stain so I just got
rid of it I'm going to go to DXL I'm
going to get a couple of te's I'm going
to rock the uh the Polo hoodie that you
got me for a little while till things
till things uh you know straighten up
and then redo the Wardrobe in the in the
spring and the summer maybe get a
stylist I don't I don't know love that
love that for you big man yeah it's
great dude start doing a little H&M or
something I mean I barely get an h& what
ham and
macaroni sounds delicious those cloth
come pre-stained however what uh I was
going through stuff and the only thing
that I was really really hard pressed to
throw out is this pair of pants that
I've had for I think 15 years okay do I
know this pair of pants buddy I have
worn these to everything we got a are
they got a pick of are they somewhat
significant that I would know or they
just like a regular pair there are olive
green dress pants that have a that have
um uh what's it called expanders elastic
in the thing okay they're not elastic
but they they're not not elastic they're
not not elastic they're elastic
undercover they don't look like elast
they don't look like sweatpants they
look like regular dress pants and I
these things they had some type of
magical power are these the joggers no
they're not the joggers I don't think I
know what you're talking about dude I
wore them to every wedding every funeral
it was the one thing that I had that I
could throw on they made me look
skinnier I was able to wear them under
the belly over the belly I swear to God
they shrunk and expanded the way that
the way that the the glove in um
Infinity wars did it's like The
Sisterhood of the Traveling fat ass dud
it was crazy they always [__] came
through for me it had a huge me ball
stain had an oil stain on it that like
would just disappear and come back mhm I
had a call dude it was like it was like
the storm on Saturn it would just come
and go man they dude and I I was looking
at them and I'm like man these things
have been with me like every everything
every single thing that I ever had to go
to they were there for you I wore them
wow yeah pull them up you might remember
I don't think I know not that you
idiot that's my blue jacket though there
you go the title of the email was jacket
first man fy's on production it's it's
bad news let's go back to that jacket
though real quick all right you want the
jacket all right not too shabby I
remember that jacket man you're sucking
in though or there's no your shoulders
are you're that's not how you I've been
working out not saying you look great
but that's my lats that's not how you
stand my glutes nobody nobody just
casually tries on clothes like somebody
rolls up on you your hands you got a
fist clenched talk about not relax you
for sure messed your hair up a little
bit Paparazzi was in my
bedroom how many of those were taken
before that one that's one and done baby
I'm a one take kid what are you talking
about ask any director I've ever worked
with I'm in and out you'll have to find
them at their day
job ask ask about the
specials get a signature cocktail help
them out any director I've ever worked
that jacket right there I purchased at
Kmart I remember yep and I rocked that
for a while that thing now was that
Kmart of Aster place I believe was place
man that place was out of business but
still open at the same time you dude a
Kmart in Manhattan you'd go in there man
I was iy was keeping the lights on it
that dump that place was rough man I
remember going there after work like
once a week just trying to find
something to wear to like an open mic or
like some guest spot we had or want to
hang out but that jacket that jacket
fits again it's crazy that's awesome
that's great it looks good theoretically
it fit I would put an undershirt on if I
were you that I would just between you
and me man look at that belly button
holy moly Hatachi but yeah okay that
guy's got the winter Blues too that
thing your belly button looks like the
Millennium Falcon's about to fly out of
it getting chased by a giant
worm uh crazy to fly into an asteroids
that looks good though you look great
you are getting your figure back ma'am
so the pants go to the pants I don't
know how like they look big somehow that
picture just got
bigger yeah those pants man those pants
I could commercial I could wear them
with anything and they would look good
cuz I used to be a fatter piece of [__]
how you did it's the first product made
to make you fatter just like these pants
used to fit you don't remember them I
don't remember well I wasn't a lot of
funerals and weddings with you any job
interview dude I literally they were my
go-to is that a pair of Oak Hills that
I'm reading right yes they are where do
you see that you see the label I know I
know it said oakill trousers when I see
shut up the Oak Hill man talk about a
hill I'll die
on of heart disease dude those things
you walk into a job sir are those oak
kill pants I mean I know you were you
know when when we were coming up you had
a couple of outfit the the interview
outfit dude you throw you throw an
oversized white button down on those
things and tuck it in with a cheap tie
and a winter coat man I was I was never
big I never had KY Bank never stood a
chance give the kid an account all those
shitty job interviews we would go on to
try to get jobs to keep you in New York
staying in New York to pay your bills so
you could you could do comedy uh I was
always a paac khakis I had a pair of
shoes they were more like uh like low
top Chucks but they were all black so I
could get remember them I could get by
with those as dress shoes paired well
with a trumped up resume yes lied on
resume you wearing Chucks no they were
all I think what are you on the hooers
basketball team I did I did look like
and real low no I look like a I look
like a I look like a high school hey
schi GNA make the
game I look like a high school
basketball coach from the 40s yeah I
would wear passionate about the
mid-range
jumper the bank's open boys it's there
for a reason use the glass today we'll
be working on the
Skyhook yeah you know what I'm talking
about of course those are my tried and
true Rider those things have had my back
for the last 15 years and are they too
big now are you back into those where
where did those fall I didn't even try
them on it was just I didn't I just I'm
done uhuh I'm listen it took me a few
minutes with that one with them where I
was like man
thank you thank you for getting me here
had a Sig with him outside let going to
catch a heater reminisce about all The
Lies We Told that I had the vet put him
to
sleep man yeah right down to trash
[Laughter]
shoot there's some homeless guy walking
around in a big set of Oak kills right
now living large he maybe he'll get a
job a job yeah he'll [__] turn it all
around with a set of Oak kills I feel
bad because I didn't do that I did
didn't fold everything and take him to
whatever listen I who wants my stained
shirts though 5x no there's a lot of
there a lot of that stuff now that like
they there's like a big thing like in
like the the not Fashion World like
clothing world where like they now they
used to make it for the season now it's
like they've made the there's a lot of
clothes that just get thrown away Andor
donated like very quickly I donate a
bunch of stuff but it's also like who
wants a 4-year-old H&M t-shirt it's like
that that thing's got like two days left
on it you know what I mean I'll take it
yeah if anything you should be
apologizing for not recycling it with
batteries and stuff [__] having the
HazMat team should be in a goddamn
Museum man I'd like to run a black light
on on those
B see that from
space it's a thousand generations of
folies in those oh my glowing like the
Aurora Borealis those things lot of is
that a pair of Northern Lights I see a
lot of pea stains those those elastics
used to give me a a burn right here
start a forest fire with those things
yikes that's uh that's great though yes
I salute you my friend thank you for
everything that's very good a lot every
dirt bag uh myself included and probably
most of the listeners uh have I still
have those clothes they're just a little
nicer and not as worn now like I still
like I don't have nice clothes I have a
suit or two I can wear to a wedding
usually fit in and out of it uh but like
I have a pair I I get them all the time
I just reup I get a pair of [__]
khakis from
the Gap you know $39.99 make sure they
fit I buy them a little big because I've
been fluctuating you know what I mean I
and I have like one or two button-ups or
like a black v-neck sweater that I can
wear to an event a funeral a something
and I don't look like an [__] I still
operate like that I got two things I can
wear I'm going um I don't know what it's
called they're like Court clothes yeah
exactly those are my court clothes right
there of course I still I I still roll
with a court outfit but I want to go
from here on out I don't want to I don't
want to go back to that like I remember
what I wore to my dad's funeral and I
looked like I was like an usher at
church sure it's just that whatever that
style of you know 9s dad pants dress
pants are I don't want to do it I like
the I like the the tapered leg little
style Jean style yeah some a little
little style to it yeah yeah but man
look at you that's great man yeah it's a
new Foley a new day 2024 new you who
this spent about a half an hour looking
for a bag of Y yaking them pockets sh
got them up see see what we got I wore
these two her bachelor party
one get some Nummies out I remember
wearing those and dress shoes with no
sock like it would literally I'd be able
to taper them to the season oh no I know
yeah yeah yeah I'm very aware throw
those on with a pair of I dude I wore
those to a wedding in Hawaii I wore them
to a funeral in Upstate New York job
interviews dude you name it right from
the office to happy hour baby as they as
they said in baby
boy
styling that's great love them K let's
talk about liquid Ivy liquid I visal
baby I'm not talking to you Gym Rats out
there we're talking to the dirt bags
yeah now we like the gym rats don't get
me wrong if you're doing your workout
you want to power yourself through
liquid IV double hydration gets in there
a lot quicker in water but we're talking
to the scumbags the guys that stay up
all night boozing doing this doing that
going in to work dying in the morning
get yourself some liquid IV if you got
that whether it's the Colombian flu or
you feel just Sicky little hair a dog
dude do yourself a favor man when I had
a fever last year I always say it that
powered me through love it my my go-to
hangover cure uh as I get home I used to
to get water liquid IV at night wake up
let it let it do the fighting for you
while you're snoozing while you're off
in Dreamland you're getting hydrated has
no artificial sweeteners so you only get
that you don't get that gross aftertaste
it's just one little you mix the little
package into a 16 oz of water Shake It
Up bada bing bada boom you're out the
door uh weekends are for going wild have
a game plan for Monday with liquid IV
grab your liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free and bulk nationwide at Costco
or get 20% off your first order when you
go to liquid i.com and use the code
garbage at checkout that's 20% off your
first order when you shop Superior
hydration today using promo code garbage
at liquid i.com do it do it this is
pretty litter pretty litter now I'm not
just a spokesman I'm also a client a
player president big pretty litter
family over there at the household I
know they just shipped a bunch more here
right now I've been buying it like an
idiot uhhuh like these Rubes out there
hey get the free stuff straight from the
straight from the plug you know what I
mean I'm telling you right now man my
girl is real careful about what she uses
with the cat and she loves pretty litter
because no odor no odor no odor you
couldn't even tell right in front of you
she could be dropping a deuce right
there smells like roses your girl how
dare you but I'll tell you this you know
the best part about it that if there's
something going on with the cat it
changes color sure shows ear the
crystals change color to indicate early
signs of potential illness in the cat
and that's that's giving us a heads up
and we took we took the cat to the vet
and she's like yeah she has a little
urinary thing going on twitched her food
switched her water take care of it yeah
u u kidney issues and more uh you can
count on pretty litter to keep your
house smelling fresh and clean and so
can you baby uh go to pretty lit.com
garbage to save 20% on your first order
that's prettylitter.com garbage Tove 20%
on your first order prettylitter.com
garbage terms and conditions apply see
to site for details do we I had
something I wanted to talk about I went
to a very fancy dinner is that right
last week oh I know the spot you went to
the Continental oh in is that is that
what it is that's it that so it's what
is Del mono Delo Del mono State cast
it's from like the 1800 a friend of
mine's a server there nice so he came in
uh it's owned by serbs apparently so he
he's Serbian so he was like yo come
through he's like I can't do much on the
bill but I'll be able to you know I
kidnapped for somebody for
you my my appetizer is just someone's
thumb here you Mr kiy uh Jesus Christ
who ordered the international phone
cards I'll take two passports for me and
the lady please your clean blood will be
ready in a
minute um one thing uh very very fancy
joint uh get dressed up no I left here I
went from here straight there I had
jeans on a a dirty pair of Air Maxes let
in there like that a black T-shirt uh I
snuck in the side door I didn't know it
was is that true I didn't know yeah well
there's like a bar that connects it I
walked into the bar and then from the
bar into the into the main restaurant
sure I didn't know so I kind of slid in
slid in the back a little bit missed the
coat check uh love a coat check so this
is what so we got uh me and me and the
lady got the uh the porter house for two
nice uh like you do when you go to a
steakhouse you get the two cuts of meat
I found that out now any uh friction
between she likes it this way you like
it that way you're both medium people uh
well as you know when we go out I'll do
you guys ruin relationships you're
medium rare gentleman medium rare medium
rare plus I'll do medium rare uh when
I'm with the team but if I'm doing if
I'm ordering my own steak I'd get it
medium well I would typically if I'm out
by myself I would do uh I do a medium
but when we're with the team I do a
medium rare because I defer I'm I don't
try to make you know no fuss no mus and
also when you do the porter house for
two some parts come a little medium sure
you know on the outskirts and that's
where I tend to live in those situations
but uh we had some steak left over
obviously it's just me and her a lot of
you know a it's a big por house a lot of
beef a lot of meat left over and plus we
like taking a bone home for hansy Ponzi
what' you do with the sides finished
them if that's what you're
asking they didn't St those hash browns
didn't stand at chain hash browns cream
spinach traditional drought yeah but
it's a very elevated it's like more fine
dining so it's like a
little in the you get a little fast and
loose with the with the potato sometimes
what do you mean are you atin man I'll
do anything kid Li Kid Likes an atin who
don't it's the best dude if I go to a
place and they got a nice Tater I'm hey
what do you what Tater are you known for
I like them as a kid but they never
really deliver the
atine scallop potato sliced or whatever
real nice and a nice creamy cheese sauce
we had one not too long ago that was
pretty good I got a scoop at them
somewhere yeah walking that back pretty
quick Hey
fat I hate them I actually had them last
weekend for breakfast they were
delicious look get my
pants my lucky pants let them go baby
but this was a very classy move that I
have never seen so obviously you know
it's what been well documented early on
in the show too that I'm not a I'm not a
leftover guy I don't like taking
leftovers sure right uh what was the app
situation can I ask sure you can uh app
situation was uh we did a Bara mhm we
did what did barata come with a little B
no it was very it's like very it came
with like a peach something that's nice
I didn't love it that was the only thing
I didn't that was the only thing I
didn't love I love a grilled Peach uh
summertime on the grill it's nice crab
cake and a Caesar s whoa yeah heavy on
the apps I'm a I'm an cocktail yes three
Manhattan
W yeah maybe four uh I was drunk he like
the Dutch down there man so uh but I'd
like to get like to get your take on
this move they come over right and
there's like multiple bus boys wait like
they're wait you like take a sip they
fill front waiter back waiter they're
all that they're they're killing it
killing the game they're they're coming
table nice table they're coming over
they're enter two top four top four top
really yeah huh uh-huh for me she had
her
own so they go we box this up like yeah
we'll just take the you know we're just
going to take the one more follow
question you said you missed the coat
check were you sitting there with your
coat hanging on the back of your chair
like a loser I had it on I don't want
anybody rooting through my pockets I got
hard candy in there there might be blow
laying around in there uh yeah no it was
on the back of the chair at that point I
was I did look I was the only one with
it on the back of the chair D the
waiter's friend you got to take that and
drop that off you got to straighten out
the Cod check girl they work hard too uh
love breaking off the Cod check girl
sure well here this well this is this is
very in the world so we ask for they go
okay we'll wrap this up just to meet we
go yeah just just just the steak and the
bone if you don't mind sure thing they
come over and just drop a coat check
ticket on the table number 15 I go
what's this all about they go oh we keep
it over either like heated or
refrigerated by the front door for you
and they go so you don't look like an
[__] with a [__] big bag sitting
on your table while you're trying to
enjoy your dessert or your after dinner
cocktail yeah you already have your
parka hanging loser I'm out the front
door smoking
what I'm outside that's a great [__]
oh great Saturday live Club oh the best
the best casy Affleck at the dun ply in
the movie they shot that at a Dunkin
Donut or a donut spot by my he but
classiest move I've seen in a very long
time yeah and he goes yeah we just
started implementing this it just the
guy you greased a person you picked the
ticket up from yes nice yeah yeah yeah
yeah you just walk over you go here's my
ticket and they turn they like walk
behind this little thing here you go
it's all bagged up you're out the it's
[__] fantastic now don't forget it I
have to ask some recent or some not in
that long ago transgressions in this
situation it was a friend that got you
in friend that that that that was
serving you that was a very specific
thing but sure he wasn't my friend
wasn't serving up okay continue what
anything off the check yes really
precisely what you had asked or what you
had said drink and desser drinks and
dessert both off both off wow I think he
knocked that's a lot of liquor I think I
had three Manhattans she had two
mocktails like there was like you dud
they that's a cool 120 right there they
ain't CH mocktails they whack you over
the head for 18 bucks godddamn pineapple
juice it's like babe get a [__]
Whiskey on a rocks or something [__]
save me a couple give free drinks here
give me save me a couple of bucks
mocktails so he wiped four drinks off I
think wow yeah okay so he charged us for
one in one I think we each had three
okay uh and dessert was waved too nice
what was
dessert some sort of chocolate something
with a little little bit of ice cream
yeah just did we each did a little bit
do an espresso like a gentleman no okay
did another Manhattan once I heard once
I heard they were
free I didn't know it was open bar I
never met an open bar I couldn't be hey
here's an happy couple
everybody yeah but uh classy joint uh
took care of him obviously I'm gonna
need a number unfortunately
um I think well we talked about this
this is okay this is more in the weeds
here we talked about this cuz to me
there's a Thing If you over he's a
friend of ours right so if you overtip
he didn't wait on you it's a he did wait
on us oh he did okay yeah and it's a
little too tacky if you're like here's
$400 like it's weird give it back to me
when I see in the building it just make
me look cool in front of his
brao um I forget the actual number but
the percentage was about 37% tip okay
and the ride home what do you mean like
he hopped in our Uber on the way home oh
okay I thought he gave you a ride home
got to check this place out that's
service right there that's door to door
help kby move a couch great guy yeah
okay and then he got knocked off early
and uh he's like he I'm heading home
we're like a so you know not bad hop in
a car took care of them I don't want to
I feel like weird of like oh here's a
lot of money it's like what are you
doing
it's got to be in a certain he knows you
ain't got
it I'm need half
that uh no just uh guy table four in a
hoodie a very heft I might have had a I
think I had a t-shirt on a very Hefty uh
a very Hefty tip
Fair um Del Monaco Del Monaco CC J down
there in a financial district I think
yeah I don't I don't I don't Venture off
down there uhuh but classy Operation God
Continental John Wick sure very classy K
be paid with one giant gold
[Laughter]
coin he had a Sig nine on
him [__] running and shooting at the
same
time Tomahawk bone in your
mouth he killed a guy with a
t-one good [__] yeah not bad um but all
that neither here nor there folks we got
a gosh darn Family episode on got
business to get to at 24 and we also got
Live show tickets on sale right now go
get them the true to roof tour look at
us boys them shows are going to sell out
lot of theaters in there lot of theaters
which is very yeah I going back to spots
we haven't been to in a while uh
Syracuse Albany back to Rhode Island and
the Wilbur we're doing the the [__]
Wilbur dude that's crazy Boston let's go
we're doing a couple of real big venues
throughout the country which is really
[__] cool uh yeah we love you guys
thank out uh for all the [__] support
it's been fantastic uh all that being
said it is a gosh Dar family episode and
when you join a patreon we will read
your question on the air uh patreons get
the first crack at it uh this one's from
Jessie B shout out to you girl never had
one read is a garbage to hold the legs
for your mom during a keg stand jeez me
come on
that's what where uh I don't think I've
ever been anywhere with my mom where a
keg stand was happening that's something
a graduation party or parents weekend at
a college parents weekend at a college I
never got to experience that me either
um that was I feel like that was big
college stuff that was big you that was
like Penn State [__] well we had it I
went to Temple we had my mom grew up
[__] 15 minutes from it she's like
running from your lives running from
your lives I was like [__] I'm not
hanging out in North Philly for the
weekend I [__] been there done that
worked my ass off to get out of here um
I mean there was always those parents
back in the day that IDE imbibed a
little too much at a graduation party
you know somebody would end up doing a
cake stand or something like that uh
someone's dad tearing an ACL playing
beard dye or something yeah something
like that there was always yeah there
was yeah there was always like he got a
little too mad someone made one of the
kids made a comment he got a little butt
hurt like that [__] happen yeah so yes
that's 100% garbage you think yes and I
I would I'd be curious to find out what
the event was could have been a funeral
or something like that I mean I think if
you're mom's lining up to do a keg stand
probably breaking the frats record dude
yeah that's tough dude mhm that's tough
I we were never big cake this B ta the
cake never had a deal with that and
would have would have not appreciated it
what having to deal with like my mom
you're like oh dude Foley's mom's
awesome I would I'll kill you I'd grab
her by the hair and take her out front
for a
talking the hell you doing it ha are my
friends and clean yourself up make me
sick get out of here uh the only real
time I ever did keg
stands um sure we did them in like a
tailgate like but like they were never
big we were never real big keg people
never did one um my buddy got one uh
shout out to Tommy Tommy got one at his
house on like a random he was like yo I
got a Kake that was always fun that dude
it was like so spare of the moment
everybody's just sitting at their house
we're driving around looking for
something to do we're probably 19 or
something like that The Keg just next to
the couch he's like I got a k he had a
pool I got a k come over him having
people in the backyard nothing big so
there was only like 20 people I love
nothing big love nothing big I'm a big
fan of nothing big tight Circle hanging
out chilling nothing big for me anymore
is like four guys nothing big It's Pat
flip Deli Jeff nothing big that's it
that's all 2K yeah it's late late night
uh and the rule I I I mean that ended up
you know ultimately killing me the rule
was in order to fill your cup up you had
to do a keg stand
that beat your last number of seconds
yeah see all that dumb [__] just let's
get messed up and it's I was 19 so
you're trying to you know I was an I
started off my first one was like 22
seconds so I had to keep doing that just
to get a beer every time you said it was
a small circle how'd they get you up
there had a pulley
system he had two kegs and a bobcat it's
crazy
your bow cut hanging down I'd have a b
cut at 19 a [__] [__] bow cut at
19 yikes uh but man that got me that was
like one of those that was the first
time I was had access to a keg full
drink like that was when you just drink
until it's gone like you don't really
know all of your limits man and they
they found me like four doors down
Vinnie with the skinny found me sleeping
in some kids some some guy's front yard
I don't know what where I was going I
figured I was walking home and I
probably stopped to take a pee or a
heater I tell you what passing out in a
random front yard in the suburbs in the
summertime back in the day not a care in
the world I would have slept there that
grass smelled great oh just cut man I
was I'll never I drive by the house
every now and then I go man that guy had
no idea I was out there [__] with
sleep apnea [__] sa and wood in his
front
yard hey Ruth I think we burst the pipe
out front is there a sewer M break nah
kippy's
we got a ceg in one of my apartments in
Chicago and I woke up in my downstairs
neighbor's couch uh fully nude with a
towel around me oh nice and he had
friends in from out of town who had
never been to Chicago before and they
were like we were to talk the next day I
just woke up ran out of there and they
were like we just thought the city was
crazy you came in you took a shower we
like man it's different up here dud a
shower I took a shower and passed out on
their couch bunch of Country Bumpkin we
did not know each other that well
not friends afterwards yeah they were
like this is crazy I was like it's
mostly a crime yikes oh god um all right
let's see here uh speaking of this was
from D this one's I this one I have
never thought of use pronounce drunk
with a J as in drunk drunk he's drunk
where is there
J
like yeah for sure I'm drunk j d r u n k
drunk would it be drunk drunk drunk yeah
he drunk he's drunk drunk man I was
drunk yeah it's a little Southern I feel
man I was drunk he's drunk yeah but I
feel like the Dr and the J it's right
there sounds the same drunk I don't
think I'm saying it differently but they
drunk and drunk the good news is either
way you're hammered having a good time
wake up in the neighbor's front yard Ah
that's a good one drunk man I feel like
that yeah he was so drunk drunk drunk
you're drunk you're drunk oh man yes I
am thanks for noticing good thing I
didn't waste all my money on nothing if
you'll excuse me those hot pockets are
calling my name man shout out to a Hot
Pocket I haven't had one in a long time
I love them
[__] uh all right this one's
from Tommy beans first time long time
never had one read you ever celebrate a
family member's birthday at an OTB it
was Uncle Dave surprise 50th and he
liked playing the pony R Uncle Dave man
I don't think I've ever been inside an
OTB I have
Philly is that right or maybe New York
it had to be otbs to me which I learned
on what happened to them they all went
away because of the internet right I
guess the only o I mean they used to be
a good time there start booze in there
if I remember I don't think so otbs can
you get a look on that do OTB sell booze
I will that's off track betting off
track betting for horse races uh
definitely new yor York City I could
have swore they had a bar in there I'm
sure oh maybe I have no idea but none on
the I used to watch a lot of Law and
Order and they always got the per at an
OTB Hey where's Jimmy at he didn't show
him to work and when he's not here he's
usually down at the OTB and he never did
it but he was always he knew what was
going on he was get in the wrong place
at the wrong time type thing um he'd
give Chase yeah they'd have to chase him
at the back door sure something he's
coming he's coming get his hands on him
yeah those forearms of his Jack them up
man um but we we grew up next to
Philadelphia they're otbs that serve boo
serve booze yeah right are they is any
still banging still around uh you think
they would have like uh grown with the
times right I think now you can probably
put them online like all like the the
racetracks you don't get the atmosphere
and stuff like that still do it online
or I don't know have a couple of slots
or something do a brunch nothing
something to bring people in nothing off
track
brunch in see there you go I'd go dude
if I can catch heaters have an omelet
and let bet some we got to go bet on the
ponies I it's so fun it's such a good
time I've never been I'm so down dude
when they're racing live it's a blast
you're hooting hollering screaming go to
Philly Park Philly Park on Saturdays and
Sundays you used to be Bob B you rolling
with a cooler we'd [__] post up let's
go watch the [__] we're going for the
day they start at noon they run till 5
you're just there [__] I'm not trying
to watch the races I want to see jockeys
get pelted with CO's lights now
now that I I'm Jun now that I think of
it I've been to Philadelphia park with
my entire family oh yeah we used to go
and I for sure had some money on the
action my mom put in a bet for me yeah
we so my listen I remember eating there
too I think we had brunch there oh yeah
the at the catian room that's the name
of the restaurant yes is that the C yeah
do we my Aunt Mary my mom she had the
itch for the ponies yeah so we used to
go I I used to go as a kid with my exep
mom's dad Jimmy he liked the ponies he
was a Gambling Man so he would take us
quite the
pedigree Christ it's a temporary
grandfather my now ex
Stepmother's Dad okay so he would be my
step grandfather who I have two of them
I have I had we just called him
Jimmy did you call him
Jimmy you didn't call him pop or
anything like that oh no oh maybe Mister
his last name no oh my God I don't know
what I call him yikes Jimbo you know
what's real trash is the mister and then
the first name like Mr Jack yeah that's
bad dude we we switched for some reason
we switched elementary schools when I
was a little kid in WLS Berry he I ran
out of
town what are you talking about about
for some reason we had to leave in the
middle of the night s about some missing
Milk Money your your M was fixing bets
down the race
um and we went to another Catholic
school we were at St Nicholas St Mary's
in wbury then we went uh somewhere else
and they did that because my uh my
teacher was like Miss suie yeah that
always freaked me out teachers would do
that I don't like that especially for
younger kids they would I don't like it
Miss suie Mr Bill just give me you Mr
Bill that don't work yeah give me a last
name yeah but if you're like seven and
you can't pronounce kositsky or whatever
it's [__] just call me Miss Jamie you
know what I mean let's make it [__]
easy how about just Jamie why are we
standing on ceremony here huh we're all
friends you're hting on her hey I about
lose that so it's Miss I see I'm going
just call you
Jamie look I'm not going to stop calling
you
uh but yeah so we would go as kids that
was my first that was my first foray
into the track and like I would bet he'd
be like hey give me you know what what's
the name or what number do you like that
kind of thing yeah real scientific
that's when I first learned the Trifecta
the win placing show I learned that at a
young age man all downhill from there
huh you ain't lying talk about getting
the hooks in you then when we were
started 17 at 18 you were allowed to go
there and bet when you were 18 but this
was
2002 or three three four whatever they
weren't carding you if you looked at so
we would go at like 16 17 18 and Gamble
and bet the hor we were just looking for
Action you know what I mean so we would
go there as kids and then we would you
know once you but then you couldn't
drink when you were there so you had to
go sober which 250 on here come Sunshine
yeah that was the first horse I no no
Here Comes Sunshine from no I know I
know the first uh let me get a saw buck
and here comes Sunshine no the first
Captain Nemo Captain Nemo in the third
in the Fifth Fifth godamn um his mother
was Mother his father was Mother he
loves to slop uh shelter rain was the
first horse I ever won on me and my boy
Paul went and bet five bucks on
shelter's rain to win and he hit hit at
like 20 to one or we were Caked Up he
couldn't tell me [__] yeah let's go all
right let's do the ponies this it's a
great time head down there I've lost
every bet since they always seem so far
away or like so far away from the
parking lot oh well it's a sprawling
property yeah dude I remember as a
little kid being like where are we going
mhm we out of here this ain't the mall
yeah dude just posted up with big
coolers just [__] cut off jean shorts
at tank top just crushing letting it
ride yeah I'm with it kiy this is blue
we're talking mushing Wings baby don't
act like you don't know what I'm talking
about woo man something you can swing
from you want to feel like you're 25
again get yourself some blue MH and the
copy it says do you remember doing it in
the morning in the afternoon in the
night no but I always wanted to it'd be
cool if we could and I'd like to do it
again listen I'm 48 years old or I'm
going to be 48 years old my
Drive is in the turlet it's down there
sure but I'll tell you what one of those
bad boys feel like you're back on the o
line again big guy blue 42 red dog man
Rock Solid the red dragon Rises From the
Ashes back in there blue fantastic when
the mood when the mood strikes and you
really want to put on a performance man
yeah it's like having Elton John's
backup band with you uh blueo is unique
online service that delivers the same
ingredients as Viagra SE Alis and litra
but an aable tablet at a fraction of the
cost uh you can take the tablets any
time of the day so you can plan ahead or
pop one whenever the mood is right the
best part is it's done all online no
talking to a doctor in person no waiting
in line at the pharmacy everything you
need is sent right to your door in a
discret package so the neighbor don't
got to know they'll just hear you
knocking boots I want them to know hear
you shooting a scene know we're open for
business Blu wants you to have better
sex discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and do it baby we
like Rhymes over here we got a special
deal for are you garbage listeners try
blue Chu for free when you type in the
code garbage at checkout just pay $5 and
shipping that's blue.com promo code
garbage to receive your first month free
visit blue.com for more details
important safety information and we
thank blue for sponsoring the Pod yes we
do all right let's see here this is from
John Carver ky's left eye shout out to
it $10 homie never had one read is it
garbage to
remarry your wait hold on I'm sorry is
it garbage to remarry with your first
wedding ring both of us plan on doing it
so this is a second marriage for both of
them and they're using the tainted metal
from the first wow those are tainted
Jewels you can't roll with that that's
bad luck that's bad luck or is it maybe
like two negatives make a positive maybe
let's give it one more shot huh I don't
that I you can't reuse engagement rings
right I don't know what these people are
doing you maybe reuse the stone did he
give that back I think it's protocol I
think the thing is the legal thing is
like if you get legal yeah I think if
the wedding whoa whoa whoa whoa buddy
he's talking about legal here if it's
not given to on like if you don't if you
can look this up Tbone if you don't look
at if you don't propose on like
Christmas or their birthday because then
it's viewed as a birthday print like
it's viewed as a gift rather than like
uh that's always what I heard from dirt
bag family members why I always propose
on January 5th that's that's what I
heard from my ex stepmom's grandfather
that's what he told Jimmy Mr Jimmy ask
her on a Tuesday I think there's more
legal binding if it's it's given on some
sort of uh special day I could be
completely wrong that just and you
wouldn't want it back would you if it
was like out if it was like 10 grand or
something yeah you [__] want it back
the [__] she going to do with it she's
out there TR [__] scat running around
with my [__] d
so the engagement ring is ruled in most
courts as a conditional gift yes
conditional upon marriage correct so
then no more marriage no more gift you
get it back whoa unless it's on a
birthday or Christmas you know that was
a Christmas present okay there you go
see shout out to Jimmy boy I could see
taking the two Rings The Two wedding
rings and having them melt it down and
making two other rings out of them I I'm
going to start giving all of my gifts on
condition like on what like here's your
lightsaber but I get to play with it
that's pretty
good and then if I don't the suits are
calling that was a shot at me you think
um yeah I don't think you should do that
but that's just me it's that to me I'm
like a weird OCD bad mojo guy that just
doesn't seem start fresh not even that
it's bad mojo just start those aren't
even that expensive right the wedding
rings I I don't think so couple hundred
bucks or whatever mine was $1.99 that's
$1.99 got it on Amazon did you really
yeah wow mhm ohuh okay my wife said she
still had it and I was kind of shocked
and she's like well why would I get rid
of that I'm like yeah that's a good
point I don't even think of that [__]
throw that out one
day going to Pat that onto one of my
kids 1190 I better hold on to this I got
this on Prime
day the day of the wedding it
arrived um all right this one's from
Gunner M $10 homie is it garbage if you
already have more saved for retirement
than your parents oh God that's a tough
look I don't oh I don't either um but I
could see how that would ha like I'm
friends with people where that would
happen right where like friends of
people that that have done that have
been doing well for a while stocking it
away it's also based upon their parents
not doing great sure let's say not
[__] on it but like let's say their
parent was more of a blue collar like
mechanic or something and they got a job
as an accountant and were like they were
raised with no money so like the second
they get it they're like I'm counting
every penny I'm pinching at Penny and
like I now have more they're just better
with money because they grew up without
it which my parents were tight with
money but they didn't have any real
savings I don't think it was all
spinning plates with Patty all credit
this credit that same with us yeah
there's no real Nest
Egg yeah I don't know it's uh we never
learned I mean my my dad owned a
business that would do well sometimes
than not great a other times and it was
I never heard of a 401 a retirement I
there was never any sure money for the
future it was like coming and going yeah
it was like you know if you make 10
bucks you spend I've heard the word
pension before pension and social
security I don't even think we had
pensions cuz they owned their own
company so I don't think they paid into
their pensions like construction like
you know I don't even really understand
what that is I'm not sure
either I think for you got to wait till
you're 65 to get it and [__] that tell
you that right now a pension is like you
I I do have one I got one with like two
grand in it from when I worked at the
law firm you do they send me monthly
statements K I want to take it out
sitting on two jods let's take it out
and we'll try to double it take yeah
that's pretty good right there you go
saing for the future pay the penalties
for getting it out I mean I only there
for 2 3 years put 80 bucks down and they
were always like hey if you put you can
put in a th000 I'm like a th000 I need
that's my money I need it now what are
you talking 65-year-old Kevin that's his
problem [__] 30-year-old Kevin's
jammed up over here crazy give me the
cash I hated that [__] I always hated
the exempt or the allowances what are
they called like you can claim like zero
or one I always got jammed up on that
claim zero you get more back or if you
claim one you get and I'm like give me
they're like well you get more more back
at the end of the year I always got
screwed on that and I never knew which
one to put and nobody when I was filling
it out could ever tell me yeah to you
yeah what's not up to what what do you
what do you put here the greatest tax
person I've ever known in my life worked
the carry out station at goino East
Pizzeria this lady knew every trick in
the book she would do everybody's taxes
at the restaurant get everybody back 15
grand and [__] like hey hey honey you
got nine kids now just so you know there
was nothing like back in the day getting
that
refund I used to plan vacations when I
would go see Nate Dean I would go okay I
know I'm getting my check mid-February
so I'd plan something for like the 20 so
I had a little bit of walking around
money and there was times I'd fly over
there with like 200 bucks in my pocket
for like a week or two weeks and have to
just be like yeah you know what do we
what you say we do hot dogs again today
just [__] lying hey these shipping
and handling fees are brutal and
plates I was such a loser I mean Kevin's
been robbed at the airport every time
he's come over here it's
unbelievable you didn't happen to see a
suitcase full of money they lost my
luggage
again they lost all my gold bars it's
the last time I fly
Lanza ah BL Vuitton luggage too you
believe that man that's got a
pillowcase
boo good for you sa saving up that's
good to hear yeah it's good for that
dude that's but yeah I do think in those
it's kind of funny to throw it in your
parents face though they got to be kind
of coldhearted especially if they're
going to need cash and you got cash if
they're like ah we can't like what the
parents I I If the parents ever need
cash and he's got do you think he tells
them if you had a bunch of money not a
bunch but like hey I'm s like and all I
think people like that are very
strategic of like this is for retirement
we don't touch this type stuff well the
key to all that is you don't mum is the
word yeah I couldn't not tell any to
your family yeah no I'd have to tell
them cuz in case something happen I have
to throw it in their face yeah I do that
when I take a long flight I tell Patty
hey if anything goes
down there's 200 bucks in my checking I
know don't pay my loans back oh that's
what I always
say say you haven't talked to me in 20
years you known me years ago did I I
don't want that did I ever tell you one
of the places I rented for temple uh
[__] I rented a place from Temple
from this guy at Temple University and
uh rented a house from him and then I
don't know call it 6 months later I
start getting phone calls from like
something something loan and something
and it ended up being an attorney and
I'm like what is this he kept leaving me
messages you know please give me a call
back so I finally home back like what is
this I don't know anybody money that's
your biggest mistake here the landlord
put me down as like a point of contact
or something to get a hold of him if he
skirts out on the I'm like dude if he
owes me 1,200 bucks to if you come
across him let me no he still owes me
the security deposit you find them
keeping there I'll be down in 20 minutes
um I owed something on a credit card or
something like that years ago this is
probably
2201 and I didn't have the you know the
means no well definitely have the means
um but you don't have to answer and once
you answer and you you give them any
type of power they got you if you just I
didn't realize I don't even know if it
was the way they did it back then but if
you just never answered if you just
never answered they would eventually
sell that debt to some other company for
a little bit less and a little bit less
and a little bit less and a little bit
less from my 20s to third for a decade I
did that but man I had this guy he must
have been an ex detective or something
this guy would leave messages that would
be like so convincing like hey you
missed the court date uh you know
they're going to come and they're going
to whatever and it rattled my brother
cuz I was staying in his apartment I
mean buddy they got Dog the Bounty
Hunter com you got to get off the ice
bro and he and I finally picked up and
it was just boom and he had me yeah
you're dead to right they start
triangulating the cell towers and stuff
you're [__] got me he made it sound
like the FBI was going to come and get
me it was like 400 bucks yeah and got it
did I ever tell you the sheriff keeps
going to my mom's house cuz I like still
technically wait what the sheriff keeps
going to your mom's house every year
since I moved to New York looking for me
I never told you that what yes he show
what do you owe it's so like for the
township it ain't for a Christmas
calendar I know that
no there's like this the sheriff were
you involved in a shootout at the okay
Corral it's his
Deputy I'm a horse thief Tbone robbed
the stage
coach knocked over a Wells Fargo Stage
Coach our chotgun
uh yeah my mom Wild Bill Ryan my mom
gets so
mad yeah dude what the ma'am well Kippy
gave me the slippy
so I'm down to down Miss I'm sorry to
intrude I know he ain't here I feel like
he stands back from the porch a little
bit you ain't seen the boy have
you and they looked me up I I never told
you you're running out the back window
and a pair pair of long
johns like high tailing away from the
out housee he shoots me in the
ass oh you got me I got
him I got
him
well I had to shoot the Ryan boy in his
H
quarters I run off into the woods he's
real calm he ain't going to make it far
he hit you with a blunder Buster or
whatever those things are called those
called a pirate
gun a blunder
Buster what he be pulling grape chot out
of his ass for a couple of week yeah I'm
real cocky real calm after he shoots me
in the butt a a blood bus
yeah I just hit him with buck shot
that's all it wasn't a
slug you stink I know dude still no I
can't have D you're running this
operation what you got local heat
looking for us it's all right it's some
some po dunk Sheriff don't say that
that's who gets me that's that's who
brings it all down so I'm a po dunk huh
your fat friend squealed on you it's
like Casino sorry kidby they had me dead
rats
you would arc on me you rat are you
kidding me you [__] rat they had me
surrounded he put a plate of beans and
some cornbread in front of me I'm
singing kiding me they got me in
[Applause]
irons you got to be kidding me dude the
sheriff's looking for you the sheriff
shows up once a year in like a squad car
not his you know he's got like oh
Clydesdale he said I would call I don't
think it's a thorough bread but it's a
nice
Steed it's about it's about three hours
by by the way the bird flies couple of
Apache Scouts like checking tracks in
the front yard drinking whiskey out of's
got a mar light he's been here smells
freshh um so I owe some weird local tax
cuz they think I'm a resed resident
there
still and I have to fill out a form that
I never I think I I think this year it's
been the past couple of months it's been
recently taken care of um I had to like
eign something man from Back East
straightened it out for
me good
gentlemen goes by the name of
Foley um yeah so he would show up every
year knocking on my door I the first man
imagine the first call oh my God D he
would have given me up in two seconds
she's like the cops are here I'm like
for [__] what ain't no such thing as
deers prison toots tell him to kick
Rock um yeah that first call I remember
getting man I was I was way behind on my
student loans they were calling
her Sher yeah it said it was taxes I
owed taxes so she started a flip now
you're not paying your taxes it's like I
think it's like 400 bucks a year or
something you have to pay to be a
resident it's like of the county or the
township or something I don't
know um it's something like hyper local
and after like the third year she's like
he lives in New York right and she's
like yeah he's like yeah I looked him up
online he's a comedian what yeah uh this
guy's tracking us so they're like place
around it you just you just have to make
you just I had Toby get my Winchester
some Bing our way out of here oh man
pumping it um yeah no just some we're
going have to cauterize wounds with hot
iron dude poers out of the fire biting a
piece of
wood Do
It um yeah no just some and like they
were like okay it was kind of like all
right we'll let it slide cuz we realiz
like he's like I would file in New York
like my taxes in New York I'm like I'm
filing as a resident of New York like
you guys figure I'm doing my part like
I'm I've done this we running from the
[__] escaping the
hangman down from The Gallows
baby 310 to the heights
huh shout out to 310 from y oh man I I
knew nothing about that movie I put that
on everybody a decade ago or whatever
like it would probably been out for a
year or two man that is a film man love
Robert
Theo who's good in that is uh Ben Foster
the best what an actor yeah man he
doesn't do much anymore does he I don't
wouldn't say that I think I think that's
like he actively kind of stepped back a
little bit I don't know okay talented
man all right why you getting in case I
end up working with him
sure um yeah so it just settled itself
very very recently um good for you I'm
pretty sure my mom did it was just like
yeah here I she sent me something I had
a loser [__] signed your death
certificate probably did he got hit by a
train oh God Bozo the Sher my mom dude
the first call because when when you
when you said that it got me thinking
about anytime that I had to like ask my
parents like to gu like to be a g like
the idea of being a
guarantor on an apartment for me in New
Y I guarantee we don't got
yeah I guarantee you don't get approved
I think we all got shot down one time
remember you were going to guarantee my
Karen apartment really yeah do you
remember that when was this uh on the
very early days of this podcast so it
would have been September of 2020 whoa
or the the summer of 2020 it was after
the thing started opening back up I had
an opportunity to get into this Rin
apartment I'm in this I had that stimmy
check sitting in my he had the stimmy
check s like a tycoon you were rich for
a minute not rich but with how little
money we you had more money than me I
had like 800 bucks or something like
significantly but like you were buying
me heaters and being like I got it you
were picking me remember you were
picking me up at work that's when I was
looking around at a
railroad some looking to buy land in
Central Jersey they they say they're
going to put a highway in it's a long
Place steel
um yeah you were and uh my mom wouldn't
do it nah my mom wouldn't cosign burned
by the sheriff what do you mean they she
never did any of like they she just I
she cosigned all my student loans and I
jammed her up real bad sure so she was
done Co like they were they were still
open like I was still 90 120 days late
on them things she's like I'm not
[__] cosign for you to get a new
apartment yeah because what I was going
to say is if presenting you wonder why I
instantly go to the worst possible
scenario they would be like if you don't
pay they'll take the house and the dog
and we'll get split up and this and it's
like all right Jesus Christ I'll get a
roommate I know what the
fu ended up at some Flop House in South
Philly that house smelled so bad yeah it
did um
but smell like G so you were going to
sign and you gave me all of your you
gave me your last three like uh bank
statements you remember any of this my
last my last three customer copies yeah
from bear Burger your last like but you
didn't have paychecks you weren't
getting paychecks or something at the
time so but like your credit you had
enough in the bank you know probably
like 1,200 bucks or whatever that like
at the moment you know what I mean like
you're like count something just hit I
can I'm presenting very well yeah or
well enough screenshot that uhhuh yes
and uh I think he ultimately he didn't
end up running a the guy just the guy in
an email turned you down he was just
like you're you were missing something
of like yeah that's not going to work so
my brother a lot of times with that kind
of stuff it they don't run the credit
check or they're just like hey he's
seems like an all right guy MH you know
what I mean yeah they ran my brother's
they so my brother had a coast man that
was a [__] call calling him I've done
that before well well in New York it
sucks cuz I think they want it to be
like if you don't make 60
times the rent a year that's what the
number is you have to have a co-signer
if you don't make 60 times the rent a
year at the time I was not give you a
weekend yeah so uh I had to have a
cosigner to get the [__] building
remember my brother having to come from
work in the middle of the
day to some broker's office and with
with a check and sign this and dude I
remember just the the pressure that he
was using with the pen to sign his name
I knew that when we got outside [__] I
was going to get [__] you five [__]
swear to [__]
God better not I got I got one Stern one
that went South quick yeah I sorry I got
one Stern one from my brother I think
via text was and that was enough it was
like I just sent him everything he
needs don't [__] this up it was just
like that like no shout out to Big
Brother also no Capital you know what I
mean it was just like lower case D don't
[__] this up definitely had a heater in
his mouth when he sent it yeah and I
have't still paying all time Auto auto
pay uh oh it's for the place you're in
now yeah I'm Coosa I had to
man I was making 600 bucks a month when
I got to play that was all I fudged all
those num I was L and international F
you know I got I got ties to Saudi
Arabia I was [__] telling them
anything they I own an oil field ties to
Saudi Arabia why deliver halal food a
lot I eat
schwarma some futures in podcasting and
boy did
I I had some call options on on a
podcast uh all right let's see here
let's do one or two more then we got a
wpp her up there gang um this one's from
Robert $10 homie never had one red is a
garbage have a sectional couch growing
up but it didn't fit in the living room
connected so you had it in two separate
pieces no that's a tough look we had
like half here and half here yeah we had
that recently my mom bought something
that didn't fit so she just broke it up
and just kept it instead of like
returning it sure she didn't think she
could return it it's a tough look two
couches with one armrest yeah yeah
that's when you see one just one just
goes nowhere you see the you see the the
raw edge of the couch that shouldn't be
customer facing bad news that's not
great no Ah that's a tough look tough
look we never had uh yeah no we I we had
this couch I mean it was like it
screamed I guess there was a couple of
bucks around 91 or something before the
divorce did you always have a sectional
growing
up uh cuz that was we might as well had
a boat the first time we got that the I
don't know I think we all slept on it
for like a week like it was like a
station the first time we got a
sectional what defines sectional what do
you mean it's got an L it's connected an
L instead of a couch and a love seat
it's two sections or multiple section it
like that slide together I got you I
always just viewed it as multiple I
guess rather than two cuz the one we had
growing up was two it was a I think it
was two three pieces and then there's
the I mean if you got a banger like that
yeah that's also a sectional too if you
got a if you have a a square no it was
it was three this way squad on there
watching movies it was three this way
three this way a big L yeah sectional
yeah I I I guess I never pegged that as
a section as a kid that Corner Spot get
in there all
the best thing was the one three pulled
out into a [__] pull out bed that's
so you'd have that and then you'd have
like the couch one oh man you get under
that pull out bed playing army guys and
[__] like that good night do power rolls
over little
WWE I was always a big fan of the Poor
Man sectional where it's just a regular
couch with the one extendo where it's
got the long the Sha
Lounge yeah that's all right that's nice
bad Tetris piece I just
iced tea stains on it a that's always so
dirty I've recently gotten confident
saying that word Shay's Lounge just Lou
the past couple of months cuz we've been
looking at furniture sure I can't I if
you would have been like what is this
I'd be like that's a big ottoman like I
would have never I would have never a
coffee table with a cushion on it yeah I
would have never been like oh that's a
sha Lounge that's not something I heard
a lot and or comfortable in the French
pronunciation Shaz Lounge or something
that's a shayy lounge bonjour hello uh
okay this one's from Joseph is it
garbage to get ran over by your great
aunt and your Grandma's driveway and
then be referred to as speed bump by the
entire family for the next 20 years
sidebar Aunt thought was absolute
garbage she would take her Dentures out
to blow heaters and drink her coffee
there you go man any we've talked about
anytime you get hit by a car by a family
member it's not a great situ it just
means like there's a lot of kids running
around there's not a lot of supervision
but I don't know who didn't I wasn't hit
by a car somebody got
hit I my there was always this like I
got burned by a cigarette by one of my
aunts by I mean hit by a car I think is
different than like you said kids
running around you know you play in the
front yard in a in a baby pool someone's
going to get someone someone's getting
run over someone's goingon to get got
yeah you get somebody's getting hurt you
GNA get this work uh yeah I don't uh I
never had we never I don't think anybody
ever got hit might I ever tell you the
story I was I had left the house I think
I was in my montigo or maybe my Luma I
think it was my Montego I had left the
house and then like I forgot my cell
phone or something so I circled back and
pulled back into the driveway and my
stepdad was backing out and I'm pulling
up and I'm like oh he's going to stop
and then he didn't and he hit your car
and he just I'm like honking and I'm
like this [__] guy's like I'm like oh
he's doing a bit you know what I mean
and then I go he's not doing a bit him
and my mom were probably like bickering
or something so he's just like Loosely
checking the mirrors and the last time
he checked I wasn't there so I'm trying
I now I got to get it out of drive into
reverse and I'm like starting to I'm
trying to back up and he's gunning it
that and he smashes me and they're so
can they hop out they're like I get
yelled I'm like you [__] hit me
they're going we thought you left I'm
like I [__] did I came back they're
like we didn't now I go you look in the
[__] mirror n you stink no [__] yeah
I'm with them the sheriff was after me
dude you man no what do you mean you
pack your saddle bags you get out of
here what a pain in the ass you must
have been for a poor guy dude who
doesn't check them you're just roll dog
in the the driveway and there's a little
hook in it trying to live his life finds
love later in
life got the sheriff showing up rotten
fat ass to deal with jamming them up
dude they were probably on their way to
happy hour or to have dinner somewhere
sure oh man you say I forgot my sh kick
who's calling you pork chop what are you
talking about you probably were I was
probably just met you and you wouldn't
stop calling
me so what happened he smashed in my car
and I got and then I got out I'm like
what the [__] are you doing and then
fall that on the ground ah they both
yelled at me and I want to be like this
is [__] this is some Twisted [__] you
got got going on over man they both
teamed up on you well that's why I think
they were mad at each other I think they
were bickering and then it wasn't hard
but I just think the jolt like that
scares like you know a fender bender you
just the noise the pop in his head what
the hell is and then turns around and
sees your big ass
k no insurance to cover that and a call
he he hit me in a car he probably PID if
it was a l he paid for it he just
smashed his car go [__] I got to fix
this
[__] fat bald idiot already stin man
friends probably waiting for him at the
shies or whatever they were heading hey
put the pretzel down and put it in
reverse yeah dude we thought you left oh
I can hear my mom I thought you left
like I [__] came back why the [__]
you breaking my stone people don't you
never forgot something and had to turn
around I thought you
left
ah I would have lost it on you too God
damn it yeah fat bastard that's what it
was cuz in their head they're like what
could he Poss possibly what the [__] are
you doing here you just left yeah I know
what you never heard of forgetting I
remember I it was stink dude it was one
of those things where they're both were
in the driveway the cars are still
touching they're yelling at me all the
car all car doors are open and I'm going
I was trying to go I forgot something
and they're yelling I'm going there's no
way forgot to ask you for money before
that's probably what it was I forgot to
go through your purse before I left any
chance you're holding
20 oh man we got to wrap it off all
right as Kippy said in the beginning of
the show The through the roof tour is on
sale right now do yourself a favor grab
some tickets come out and see us yeah
this is our biggest tour uh we've done
to date if you've been to the shows
before the last three tours you know
it's a good time uh stand up comedy me
and F each do stand up and then we close
out playing ay with you guys it's a good
time uh we want to see you out there
we're looking forward to it we'll see
you there yeah